من الضروري حقا الاستحمام كل يوم الامر
غير ضروري بحسب اطباء الجلد شرط الالتزام
بقواعد النظافه العامه
بحسب اخصائيه الامراض الجلديه في باريس
ماري جوردن فلنا لسنا مضطرين الاستحمام
يوميا من الراس الى القدمين واوضحت
الطالبه العضو في الجمعيه الفرنسيه
للامراض الجلديه ان الجلد عضو حي يتجدد
وينظف نفسه بطريقه ما
كما ان سطح الجلد وغطى بطبقه من الماء
والدهون تشكل اول حجز للقاء اذا تلوث
مشيره الى ان هذه الطبقه ضروريه ايضا
الوقايه من الجفاف
وتقاعدتين عامه يكفي غسل المناطق التي
تحتوي على العرق الذهني
لا يمكن للاغتسال بسوره المفرطه ان يسبب
الرفاف وكذلك الاكزيما وفق جولدن
لذلك يوصي اطباء الجلد بالتركيز على
الاجزاء التي تتواجد فيها الميكروبات
والعرق باستخدام الحد الادنى من المنظفات
او عوامل الرغوه التي تهاجم الجلد
فاذا اعتمدنا هذا النوع من النظافه
واغتسلنا مره كل يومين او ثلاثه ايام فلا
مشكله ما لم نتعرق كثيرا او نمارس الرياضه
[موسيقى]
يستهلك الاستحمام الكامل بين مئات 150 و
200 لتر من الماء رغم كونه مناسبا
للاسترخاء في كثير من الاحيان غالبا ما
يكون شديد الحراره او يمتد لفتره اطول من
اللازم ما يؤدي الى تجفيف الجلد عن طريق
الاخلال في التوازن في تكوين البشر
وبحسب معهد ايفاق الفرنسي لدراسات الراي
العام قال 43
انهم يستحمون بالكامل يوميا مثل جيرانهم
الالمان فيما لا تتعدى نسبه هؤلاء لدى
الانجليز اف 68% والايطاليين الثلاثه و
50%
[موسيقى]